this next gentleman i'm thrilled to be
able to call a friend and chris
uh we have already checked uh ourselves
for foreign substances three times to
make sure that this conversation is on
the up-and-up uh one of the all-time
greats 28-time emmy award winner
and baseball hall of famer bob costas
how are you sir
hey rich how are you i'm i'm conflicted
bob
i'm very conflicted yes i am what can i
do to help rich
i'm s i i i you know the pitchers you
know using all of this gunk this year
and many of them
bro bringing this on themselves but i i
i i
i don't like seeing um
hall of fame pitchers to be you know
pulling
their pants open and managers like
girardi
screaming at the other dugout come on
out let's go fight i mean
this is not what baseball should be bob
honestly i think in the case of girardi
scherzer some of this is gamesmanship
and an unintended consequence of
baseball trying to crack
down on the excessive use of these
various substances
try to get in max scherzer's head try to
disrupt whatever rhythm he's got
going and i guess they could have
anticipated that
my understanding was that unless there
was something so flagrant that it was
happening
right in front of everybody in the
middle of an inning that what umpires
have been instructed to do
is to randomly check pictures as they
come off the mound
so it would not delay the game it's the
end of a half inning
or perhaps in a circumstance where a
pitcher has been removed and there's a
break while the other pitcher
comes out of the bullpen then you check
whomever not
every time but randomly enough like
traffic stops
uh with radar enough to at least curtail
those were speeding in in this case or
those who were cheating
i didn't think it was intended to
start a parade of checking in the middle
of innings
or allow managers to use it as a form of
gamesmanship which is apparently what
happened
and then uh sergio romo turned it into a
form of burlesque
he did i mean like he went uh steve
lyons honest bob like tingling right
right
but i mean you know manfred can't want
to see pitchers taking their pants down
like i mean this is this is ridiculous
it really i think there's universal
agreement
that we don't want pitchers dropping
trowel or for that matter shortstops or
right field is dropping trowel
in full view of everybody so
um what's the fix bob uh
i have an idea i'd love to hear what
your idea is because clearly the first
48 hours and look look you you can't
also sit here and say
somebody's going to the hall of fame is
above getting checked out when i had rod
carew on last week and he said he told
gaylord perry all the time
you throw whatever you want i'll just
hit the dry side of the baseball
so what what is what is the fix in your
mind
bob costas it seems to me that what they
have to do
is identify except an acceptable
substance or one or two acceptable
substances because it is necessary for
pitchers to get a grip on the ball there
are different weather conditions
especially when it's cold
um you can recall this it seems quaint
um i can recall saying it as a
broadcaster the umpires will tell us
before a game let's say in april or a
postseason game in october
in a cold weather site you're allowed to
go to your mouth on the mound which has
been outlawed in most circumstances
because
the pitchers need something to get a
grip on the baseball not just
for their effectiveness but to prevent a
pitch from getting away at 90 plus miles
an hour and buzzing somebody
upstairs so you don't want that to
happen in factors are made that
point uh after the game last night but
they can identify would seem to me
one or two acceptable substances
available
in every clubhouse and dugout and since
a rosin bag has been at the back of the
mountain since the beginning of time
that indicates that baseball understands
that you need something
to help with the grip perhaps they can
come up with something
either in addition to or in place of the
rosin bag that would come
that would be placed on the downside of
the mound behind the pitcher
and could be used but it's mlb approved
and anything other than that if you're
found with any substance other than that
no matter what you're lame the dog ate
my homework excuse
is you're suspended and it doesn't
matter if you're a cy young winner or
the last guy out of the bullpen
uh and the question is is you know why
hasn't that happened i mean
you know manfred's smart enough
everyone's smart enough everyone knows
that
what we just saw from degrom getting
checked even though his spin rates are
lower than most despite his incredible
talent
and sures are getting checked three
times it took one
you know i guess full day uh on tuesday
uh with many teams off monday one full
day for a manager to
come across as looking like he's using
it to mess with the pitcher's head
uh i mean why are we going through what
you
referred to it is literal figurative
burlesque why are we doing this
what's going on well perhaps they didn't
uh
institute this with enough foresight uh
we know a lot of pitchers said look
uh let's institute this next year but
baseball is concerned
um i haven't checked the numbers in the
last week or so but at one point a
couple of months
into the season uh the overall mlb
average
was the lowest since 1968
which prompted the lowering of the mound
when
mlb overall hit 237 pardon me and then
later
couple years later the american league
goes to the d h
and if you take 1968 out of the mix then
the overall mlb batting average a couple
months into this season
was the lowest in modern history lowest
since the 1880s
or something like that so maybe they
felt we couldn't wait
until 2022. this is a crisis and we got
to get a handle on it as soon as we can
and that was brought on me in the fact
that they decided to
not deal with the issue um uh
in in this particular offseason and we
did you know see
spider attack and all i mean that's
crazy bob uh right i mean like i
what was the craziest substance you ever
heard was being used uh
in the last you know decades
of this patrol petroleum jelly
uh other forms of lubricant which are
designed for more intimate settings
etc etc
uh bob costas here uh
on the rich eisen show so what's are we
just gonna continue to see this
i mean what are you are you hearing
anything about what's being discussed
i mean what do you think rich i think
this is the key difference
guys have always cheated looked for an
edge some of it we looked on almost
benignly like it's interesting
gamesmanship
pardon me elston howard of
the yankees back in the 60s used to say
that he would nick a baseball
on his shin guard before throwing it
back to whitey ford and that one little
nick
allowed whitey to make the baseball do
some things that he otherwise couldn't
make it do gaylord perry
we all know and gaylord went through an
elaborate series
of maneuvers touching the bill of his
cab touching his belt touching his
jersey the back of his hair
all those things if only to put the fear
of it
in the batter's mind and to uh offer too
many possibilities for the umpires to
crack down on him or don sutton or
others okay we knew it existed
but the general impression was that it's
a handful of guys who are doing this
effectively now with
the biomechanics that have come into
play
uh with with the way
pictures are pictures train um with the
emphasis on velocity
and spin rate uh high-tech coaching
then uh then supplemented by
these various substances it's across the
board
not everybody may be as effective but a
huge percentage the consensus is a huge
percentage
of pitchers from middling guys all the
way up to future hall of famers
are using this to gain a further
advantage so you have instead of
a few little wink wink outliers the
gaylord perry's of the world
you've got an epidemic throughout the
sport
and it's affecting the appeal of the
sport
as an entertainment product when you
look back at the steroid era
it was wrong it poisoned the record
books
but you could make a case that it
actually made baseball more entertaining
for a period of time people responded to
it they may feel differently about it
through the rearview mirror
but in the here and now they responded
more or less favorably to it
no fans respond favorably to this form
of baseball
where action is suppressed where s run
scoring is suppressed
um where the strikeout rate in major
league baseball rich
the overall strikeout rate is equal to
nolan ryan's career strikeout rate
nolan ryan struck out about twenty five
percent of the batters he faced
over his quarter century career that's
the average strikeout rate in major
league baseball now
all pitchers combined this is not
entertaining
yeah i was in and you you tack it on to
uh you know the raise doing like what a
lot of teams are doing as well which is
start the opener not a starter start the
opener uh
then get yourself to a fifth inning
where you might have one lead and then
bring in one
100 mile an hour thrower after another
out of the pen and get the right mix
of uh exit velocity and spin rate and
and shifting and get yourself uh to the
world series
and i i just i i i run that i said the
you know that's akin to having the first
90s scripted in the nfl
it just it just comes across as is
not enough heart and soul and
feel and gut the whole thing and and
you know add on the spider tack after
the apple watch
after the theragun after all of that and
it's just
you know what can be done bob i guess
that's why
i said at the very beginning i'm
conflicted because i love this sport
you know so much and i know that it's
yours to love as well
so what do you think you know what you
just mentioned prompts another point
which is implied
uh it used to be that a fastball above
90
was noteworthy now like 91 92 is the
average big league fastball
and we know that a lot of guys some of
them starters and certainly bullpen guys
who come out and just let the throttle
out for an
inning or a few batters 95 plus
is commonplace so if you combine that
with additional spin rate on that pitch
and then
additional spin rate on a hard braking
slider
big league hitters are over matched in
many circumstances
the game has a certain balance and when
that balance has gotten out of whack
in the past adjustments have been made
baseballs very slow to make these
adjustments other sports
tend to do it more quickly and baseball
you know because it has its history that
you don't want to mess with
etc etc maybe it's a good thing that
they're generally slow
to change things but we can see now that
it is out of whack
again it was out of whack in the late
sixties in favor of the pitchers
it was way out of whack in the nineties
in the early two thousands because of
steroids and other factors
in favor of the hitters and now it's
back out of whack
in favor of the pitchers again and that
they have they have to
recalibrate this most most urgently
because
it affects the business it affects
baseball's an entertainment product
but it also affects competitive balance
and whatever is left of generational
comparisons
which are difficult to begin with but
whatever is left of that which is part
of the enjoyment of baseball
if the conditions are so starkly
different from one decade to the next
then then some of that generational
comparison goes away
bob costa's here on the rich eisen show
in the few minutes we we have left them
bob let's let's stroll down memory lane
let's uh
let's get let's get back to uh some
other times here
um 37 years ago today where were you bob
costas
i was at wrigley field in chicago and it
didn't even occur to me that this is yet
another anniversary of the so-called
sandberg game until i heard someone
mention it
on the air this morning um and for those
too young to remember it the key thing
here is
that the saturday afternoon game of the
week in the 70s
80s really to the cusp of the 90s
was a whole different thing than just a
random baseball game that happens to be
on on saturday afternoons now
that was the only national telecast of
the entire week in baseball
in 1984 the cable superstations that
carried the braves
and the cubs were in their infancy so if
you were in a non-major league city
that was your one chance to see fernando
valenzuela face johnny bench
or whatever it may have been um and even
if you did live
in a major league city most of those
cities only televised maybe twenty five
or thirty road games
for an entire year was an entirely
different landscape
the saturday afternoon game of the week
sometimes got ratings
of nine and ten ratings equal to prime
time
hit television shows so tony kubick and
i find ourselves at wrigley field in
chicago
it's the cardinals against the cubs so
it's classic you know we see some red
shirts in the stands at wrigley and some
blue cub
shirts and hats at at busch stadium it's
a beautiful saturday afternoon
the cardinals jump in front nine to
three the cubs come battling back
it's nine to eight when ryan sandberg
comes up in the bottom of the ninth to
face bruce suiter
and to show you how different the game
was suit has been in the game for two
winnings already
trying to close it out sandberg homers
into the left center field bleachers
to tie the game at nine nine they go to
the tenth willy mcgee doubles home iran
at that point willie mcgee is hit for
the cycle
he later scores what appears to be an
insurance run the score is eleven to
nine
two outs nobody on bob durnier the lead
off man
walks on a three-two pitch a disputed
three-two pitch
up comes sandberg again suiter still on
the mound
sandberg hits the ball to almost exactly
the same place look like the same fan
could have caught them both now the game
is tied eleven eleven
the place is going berserk and
eventually the cubs win the game in
eleven innings
twelve to eleven the game to this day
is still as the sandberg game it's a
regular season game
that has a title the only other one i
can think of is the pine tar game where
george brett
briefly had his home run disallowed
yankee stadium uh and went
berserk memorably berserk as he came
charging out of the dugout
but that could never happen today which
is not a knock
on modern baseball but there's so much
baseball available all the time
i'm sure there have been games just as
wild
and just in their own place as memorable
as what happened on june 23rd 1984
but it did not reach the entire country
in quite the same way the movie the
natural had come out only a month or two
before and at some point in the
broadcast after sandberg had a second
home run
i said we must be looking at the real
roy hobbs
uh this you know sandberg's the natural
and at that point at sandberg to this
day
says that that was the turning point of
his career it marked him as an mvp
candidate he did win the mvp
the cubs who were forlorn forever as
they usually are
emerged as a contender they came within
one win of making it to the world series
and that one game
stands out at the as the signature of a
hall of fame career and the signature of
the cubs rebirth
37 years ago today um
amazing and uh before i do let you go
and i know we've
we've chatted a while but i do i would
be remiss if i
did not ask you about marvelous uh marv
albert tonight yes making his first
of final what i hope is seven calls uh
in the eastern conference finals i grew
up in new york city watching marv
on wnbc uh locally in new york as well
as him going national and calling nixon
rangers games
on the radio as well it's part of the
reason why i sit in this chair and i've
told him that
um what are your recollections first
time you met him anything you want to
say about him
uh as he's embarking on his final
assignment starting
every kid in new york whoever shot
baskets in a gym
or in a school yard uh without without a
net
on the rusty rim uh-oh
we lost him we lost and bob is probably
sitting there somewhere in new york city
just still talking
uh bob are you there bob you're back on
uh yes i am
and you ever have this feeling usually
it happens with a cell phone not a
landline
it drops out but you don't know it and
so you're just listening to yourself
make whatever wonderful point you think
you're making
and then there's silence on the other
end of the line and for the first two
seconds you think
what i said was so stunning that he or
she has to gather themselves
before responding and then you realize
no
like someone just ranting in a bus
terminal you've been talking to no one
in particular
i'm sure it was great that's why i
wanted to call back and hear it you were
saying we we lost you
uh uh when i asked you about marv your
thoughts on marv
and you were saying anybody who's uh
playing on a basketball
uh in new york city and then both you
were gone so
i'll give you the floor again with what
you were saying with marv beginning his
final assignment tonight
as great and iconic as marv has been on
national television and that alone more
than qualifies him for every hall of
fame for which
he is eligible to fully appreciate the
whole arc of marv albert's career
you have to have heard him on the radio
doing the rangers and especially the
knicks
no disrespect to hockey but the rangers
didn't win the stanley cup until 1994.
the knicks when marv was their young
radio voice
not only won two championships in the
early 70s they were one of the most
memorable and appealing teams in nba
history because of the unselfish way in
which they move the ball
always looking for the open man and some
announcers have a style
that matches the team with which they're
associated
if we want to go way back ray scott
called many of
the most memorable green bay packer
games ray scott's style
on cbs was so minimalist so meat and
potatoes
that the way he sounded matched the
image
of vince lombardi's green bay packers
the way marv albert sounded on the radio
matched the way the knicks played the
quick
crisp staccato calls as they crisply
moved the ball
around the court ideally radio which
meant more
generations ago than than it does now
because people relied on it more
for information and also for sports it
was just more central
than it is now radio ideally is the
theater
of the mind if you knew the knicks
roster
and you listened to marv albert call a
game you didn't
just know who made the basket or who
grabbed the rebound you knew
down to the foot where the ball was on
the court you could visualize
every moment of the game his calls
elevated the way vin scully's calls or
jack bucks calls
elevated big moments for the dodgers or
the cardinals
marv albert's calls are inseparable from
that era
of nick basketball every kid whoever
shot a basket in the gym
or on a school yard someplace every kid
heard marv albert every new york kid
and there were many cries of yes when
one out of every six or seven shots i
launched
somehow found the bottom of the net yes
yes
and it counts and all of that and and
then of course you were part of the
broadcast team when
when nbc sports got the nba
and you know john tesh's round ball rock
was
brought you into a broadcast hearing
your voice first and then it would be
marv
calling the game and what was it like to
be
part of that era we saw obviously part
of it in the last dance documentary but
just just thinking about that again as
marv is wrapping up this
storied uh play-by-play correctly it
include you know
super bowls and things of that nature as
well on the radio
but i'm just wondering what your
thoughts are on that bob no disrespect
to any others who have covered the nba
cbs with dick stockton and company did a
very good job during the bird
and magic era mike greene is literally a
hall of fame
basketball announcer on espn and abc and
they've got a good thing going with
jackson
and van gundy and of course tnt the best
studio show in the history
of television sports is ernie johnson
shaq kenny and
and barkley uh on tnt and marv has been
among those doing
the play-by-play on tnt so all that
stuff is excellent but i think the
combination
of the way the games were produced on
nbc during that era in the 90s
the fact that it was the michael jordan
chicago bulls era
it also encompassed the dream team in 92
in barcelona
you got marv calling the games the games
were brilliantly produced and directed
john tesh's round ball rock still
resonates
with people um we had dramatic openings
especially for the games in the finals
that brought the games on the air that
not only kind of
uh in two minutes summed up the
narrative of where the series stood
but got you ready for the game i have
people tell me to this day i guess they
show up on youtube that they still get
goosebumps watching some of that stuff
and then you hear marv's
voice which is inseparable from the nba
of the 90s i don't think
that you can cover a league or a sport
any better than nbc did with the nba in
the 90s yeah
and then just just you know marv's voice
you know michael jordan
again you know as he's given the shrug
going up the court you know i mean
in the old chicago stadium i'm getting
goosebumps just talking to you about it
bob
you know sometimes there are some great
broadcast
calls where if you read a transcript
you say wow that's incredible the
transcript of din scully's called the
entire ninth inning of sandy colfax's
perfect game
in 1965 is poetry but
then there are things which if 99
of announcers said it it would just be
okay but
because it was someone like marv albert
in that distinctive
style saying it that's what separated it
oh a spectacular move it's by michael
jordan
almost any announcer could say those
words but the way marv albert said them
that's what separated it from everybody
else
if i had said those exact words would
have been okay marv said it was whoa
perfect perfect bob thanks for the call
thanks for the call back
thanks for all that you take care buddy
thanks man that's bob bob costas
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here